I just want to know cuz this blonde hair
is it's working we love it oh really is
it here to stay the super super black no
I mean is it here to stay
yeah like the law it would be so much
work and I can barely stand doing this
one really it's spell roll um
no I lost the bet with a friend yeah
kind of a double dare sort of thing I
did it to my little brother I think you
forgot like I grew up with Eminem like
Eminem was cool we know so your slave to
the peroxide yeah a little bit okay my
stand coming out Zac Efron taking
inspiration from Eminem and Brad Pitt
there's all bleats the Brad Pitt in
Fight Club muscles
a true fitness buff Zach just launched a
YouTube series called gym time where he
trains with his celeb pals
how are those Fight Club Brad Pitt abs
coming along they're never gonna be the
quality frat bits just change the world
who is your dream celeb you would love
to get in the gym and film with pro
athletes are very fun but somebody like
Lilly is also really funny but she takes
care of yourself I mean I watch movies i
watch sports anyone that's interesting
that likes to work out Joe Rogan I would
love to do some ballet in the gym just
be out of my comfort zone we do bar that
would be an amazing scene amazing things
I'm get to learn something new
Lilly teaches Zach how to do Forte's
I want to learn a Forte Zach certainly
flexes his acting muscles in his latest
film extremely wicked shockingly evil
and vile playing serial killer Ted Bundy
this is all gonna end it's only gonna
end attention Lilly definitely Lilly was
ready to go right then at rehearsal
perfect gave a perfect performance and I
literally walked outside and I almost
had a mental breakdown I was like we
need to get to rehearse and release
crush going for awards already know what
you're so good yeah I just sat at home
and said Zach you're gonna be better
there were days like in the prison
sequence outside when Liz comes to visit
that I just I think I pulled you aside
after and said I hope you realize how
great that was didn't I put there were a
couple of times when I was like I hope
you know that what you just did was like
that was amazing I do remember those cuz
they always appreciate them I cuz I just
didn't see Zach
unspeakable horrors of the defendants
heinous crimes
[Music]